in Northern Ireland and mid seventies we
were on the brink of seven war the study
was bombed pieces people were very
frightened there were murders every day
and there was no military solution there
was no para military solution people
were in despair they just didn't know
where to turn and in August 76 three of
my sister's little children were killed
and a young IRA mount and week he might
and we said and there's got to be
another way violence doesn't work let's
try to solve our problems through
dialogue through peaceful means and I've
brought about a tremendous release of
energy in the community that people
realized you could do something
thousands and thousands marched it was
quite extraordinary and it took time for
the peace process to convert to come and
today in Northern Ireland it's thank God
we have our peace process we have a par
sharing executive we still need a lot of
changes because we're a deeply divided
society so we haven't stopped our
working I guess it'll be a lifetime's
work trying to build genuine democracy
and genuine peace but we we have come a
long way since mid nineteen seventy six